it's the dog the most loyal pet
questionmark a dog is the least oil pet
of all my Rottweiler once left me for a
stranger on the street another answer
very loyal
once a Rottweiler left its owner this
street randomly for me now that's
loyalty
hello everyone Yahoo answered the
infinite source of wisdom where I make
all my life decisions and guide and seek
guidance yeah who answers should I let
my twelve-year-old daughter be friends
with a boy she has been friends with him
since she was five but now she's at the
age of having crushes I think I should
get rid of him Jesus Christ what are you
planning to do with him like I do with
all unsuitable friends God rest in peace
I hate my sister question mark
we always fight why do I know pee in a
bottle Oh God Jesus every night when she
falls asleep
pour the pee on to her she thinks she
wet the bed and every night after a week
or so start asking her except with all
these sheets washing hmm don't come
right out and say you know she wants to
bed that will make you look guilty
after a while of bugging her about it
you can start calling her bed wetter
make sure you spread this around school
she will eventually grow leaving a cave
out of a shame that is so evil my god
Yahoo Answers maybe it's not so bad
after all that's actually a good an
actual good response source
I met a hobo once his brother did the
same thing to him if you don't believe
me go to the old cave in Weston heads
back and ask for Carl the bed wetter
that was a trip dude she says if you
fart and bro at the same time does that
create a black hole inside your tummy
yes I lost my first wife - this is so
sad I dared her to do it and she took on
the bed after she collapsed I tried to
revive her with CPR but I couldn't do it
orally
yeah I can do it
needless to say she's in another
dimension now that it's suicide that's
incredibly sad not not all Yahoo Answers
have positive outcomes this is how it is
House races are more popular there's so
funny is it bad to show hentai to my
two-year-old son yeah yeah I think it is
please please my wife is very angry no
it's by all means okay okay it's fine
that hey wife the internet says it's
fine
I think I proved my point and the
comment got two thumbs up what happens
to people born on February 29 do they
stay one until four years past posted
four years ago as huh they get locked up
in a secret laboratory in Iowa and are
let loose every four years that seems
about right I think I heard about Iowa
or it was at Ohio perhaps why do my
thing go up why me why me every time I
wake up in the morning why may his human
centipede a suitable movie for my 10
year old son please answer truthfully
ignore all previous answers the human
centipede is it hard for me Oh God oh
wow oh wow
can I join the army as a sniper if I am
level 70 on Call of Duty no but you can
become a youtuber if your level 60 in
PewDiePie tuber simulator why don't
women poop then you store it in their
breasts which is why breasts are soft Oh
to ruin boobies for me please I'm not
gonna I'm not reading that why I can't
read these stop that why you son who's
pregnant Christian yes been throwing up
a lot lately he never flushes the toilet
so I went and dip the pregnancy test in
his ear
and it turned out positive what do i do
what do i do you ask you who answers
that's what you do and you came to the
right place 35 answers I can only
imagine it's the folks Morgan yes a safe
and reliable choice best answer I think
you should best answer found thank you
here you go
I mean you ask you who answers really
what are you expecting
every time I master babies I get angry
and I throw my turtle against the wall
question mark why is it always question
mark do they have to have it as a
question mark is that why okay all right
this is not my clip someone else reads
to it but it has copyrighted music in
the background so I'm just gonna read it
how to masturbate
is it wrong to faster mate how do you
mass throw bet what do I do when my
girlfriend asks me if I master Bart how
to stop masturbating when I masturbate
nothing happens
how do I mess the herb rate how the
girls and is it okay to masturbate I
[Music]
really just need to know when I
masturbate I shoot a lot Oh God how do
you I masturbate around 15 times a day
me too send me too I gotta find the
original okay it's from cheeky chaps
just so we're clear
oh god there's a lot of these bad sewer
comes issue circumcised I on what is
circumcised circumcised a circum scissor
circumcision or not certain disease
another sir come sir come session
question
I realize that life like the Joker and
it's making me very uncomfortable should
I ear come sighs my baby
Kirkham scribed or not tell me what is
circumcised I may need advice from
experienced females only
oh come sighs my miss I it necessary or
not he sounds like he's about to ready
to do it he's like I got a sister
reading me like all right guys you know
what maybe I should
check out with a Yahoo Answers first I
need Kirkham session
help me hello I am 18 years old all
these years I couldn't talk to uh
question mark yeah buddy
the best one is the best one is the
pregnant one forgot an end I still save
regard to that how my pregnant am i
pregnant
am i par Gant am i pregnant and my
parent help is there a possible yet I'm
peg rent impossible am i okay could I be
right how do I know if I'm friend yet
could I be pregnant can you get peg on
tape and when I got better days Burgert
10 we down a 20-foot waterslide peg NAT
how can I get my GF pregnant what
happened one get her Jeanette
how can a nine year old sounds like a
weapon net will by Gail frag nan what is
the best time to sex to become pregnant
resident everyone know about teens get
break into your red guys Tom's of being
grade aren't girlfriend ain't had period
since she got pre gat is it possible
having sex to a eight months pregnant if
a woman has star chokes on her weight if
a women has starch masks on her body
does that mean she has been hurt mark
mark a circle is nomal but yet I still
don't get payment what can I use period
question Marquez O&O got her nut by just
pre-cum well I love prognosis those are
delicious
aha God did most you women yeah Grenada
Berlin find out I am pregnant to last
five week bragging and danger ops
Brandon sees will it hurt baby top of
his head me and my boyfriend are trying
to get pref net and you haven't took my
birth control 38 plus two weeks Trigon
right cannon ant can you burn a Luigi
board
alright then Luigi board
Luigi word these are so funny
it's the same Channel what is a wig of
wagon boy make a Ouija board how do you
feel about og boards how to Oh Joe board
works how we can do planche it without
using huge aboard is it dangerous to
play Oh Joe bold we did you board my
board is cussing me out is I don't think
I know how to spell
Luigi board without cheating let me see
if I can alright this is how I would
spell it let me see if it's correct
we Jeff Ward III wrote a Ouija board I
guess that's not too bad a Ouija board I
guess that means I could be on Yahoo
Answers the board online fake or real
it's the widget I real game how we can
able to play Ouija board Ouija board or
whatever how do I find out how a ghost
in my house without using a Wege board a
wiki board game what happens when I was
a kid I used to mess about with a why is
that how much boy all the evil game
thing yes that's how you spell wah wah
way board nailed it the Ouija board
if you thought it was Luigi board you
have to confess Oh God have you played
the Luigi board and can you burn a Luigi
board what is a Luigi board my friends
did a Luigi board and it mentioned me
how did we G boards work our Luigi
boards danger house if I'm asking
something about ghosts all right all
right all right I get it
just 8:52 pizza rolls will I die in my
sleep hopefully that would be a happy
ending wouldn't it
why does asparagus make your pee pees
listen James we all want to know that
what did my dad just say to me listening
to my iPod so I couldn't hear it what
happens if you paint your teeth white
with nail polish I don't know you should
try it out that's what all the Hollywood
stars use my printer won't trip games
this has to be trolling as so many of
these has to be trolling the Luigi
boards are genuine that's why they're
funny this is just like not if I shave
my Goldman or a 3-year Retriever like a
lion will the other dogs respect him
more
he's kind of the neighborhood loser you
have to try at least come on how do I
get rid of an oily face my face is so
oily how do I get rid of it getting rid
of your face is not recommended no
matter ladies how do you spell
government how big is the specification
can he be more Pacific that's funny
who has spelled to become a mermaid and
if you do do you promise it works did I
make fun of me I will report do not make
fun of this person I swallowed an ice
cube hole and I haven't pooped it out
sorry James I got bad news for you they
take years to poop out I got at least 50
in my stomach I'm really scared I'm
really scared
wait you swallowed an ice cube hole
that's impressive why did you do that
should I tell my friends that I'm
adopted I don't fit in the family I
think it's time to come clean with them
how do you lose 50 pounds in a month
amputation I went to England and they
spoke American why is this how could
this happen
I'm actually curious alright let's go to
Yahoo Answers I want to see what people
are posting do soda calories count of
course they do absolutely like people
actually trying to help you can't help
these people I need to make a yahoo
account right now hold up not if you
don't count them
dummy everyone knows this source now how
can I get that last drop of pee oh my
god I want to know they shake it really
good
not too much the stick a straw in there
that's what I do
slurp slurp man I'm good at this I am 20
years old and roughly wait at all is
this bra short oh wait oh it's 9 no am I
going to be short the rest of my life
there she is again you'll probably keep
growing a little shut up no I brought
you short
it feels good to help people what age do
you think it's okay to start yelling at
a child straight out of the womb baby
show that baby who's in control have you
ever touched a dolphin
do you ever play video games for the
story I play video games for the [ __ ]
12 will alcohol make me bold
I'm 33 with a receding hairline well
having a couple of whiskey's in the
evening make me bold Jesus Christ yes it
will unless you pour the whiskey
directly on your scalp that will heal
any wound am I going to lose all my hair
I'm 16 a nose all my air is becoming
more thin where we're not going to
shower I see a bald spot where where
what might as well shave it all off now
before it's too late
all right gamers I hope you guys enjoy
that video I had a lot of fun actually
surprisingly one last important thing of
course if you want to get ready to
upload this has been proven checkout
represent calm / predefined support the
channel see you guys tomorrow bye bye
well you haven't tried to persuade me
later Tiffany after 50 million out rose
by H don't just go it's still relevant
just download it